[Music]
the violent world of fx's sons of
anarchy is populated by
many many bad people even in light of
all that evil company
no one deserved the ugly end they got as
much as ron perlman's claymore
for all the horror clay dragged sam crow
through pearlman's charismatic
performance of the former president of
the redwood original charter
won him quite a few fans many of whom
were sad to see moro go
series creator kurt sutter was aware of
this tension at the time he made the
decision
to permanently cut pearlman loose and
told entertainment weekly
as much as people say they want clay
dead they don't want clay dead
they want to see how gemma feels about
betraying clay they want to see how
juice feels about betraying they want to
see that play out even though they
in their gut know they know the guys
should be dead sons of anarchy ended in
2014 so you'd be forgiven if time has
put a gloss on all of clay morrow's
transgressions
with all the petty acts of murder and
dishonesty that peppered the series
it's interesting to note that clay's
most important crime actually happened
off-screen
sam crow president clay morrow who spent
so many years acting as a surrogate
father to series protagonist jax teller
played by charlie hunnam actually
murdered jax's real father and shacked
up with his mother gemma
before the timeline of the show begins
that one violent act
sets clay and jax on a collision course
that isn't ultimately realized until the
show's penultimate season
when jax finally guns down clay and
reccopence for his real dad's murder
given all the great drama that moro
brought to sons of anarchy
it's interesting that sutter decided
pearlman had to go before the final
season
as it turns out that decision had
everything to do with the rigorous
demands of the story
and the shakespearean inspiration for
sons of anarchy's tragic plot
sons of anarchy is very much the modern
adaptation of hamlet
that its creator always intended it to
be lest you wonder
who's supposed to be whom sutter tips
you off with a little naming convention
gertrude hamlet's duplicitous mother
from the play is now gemma
while claudius hamlet's murderous uncle
translates to clay
jacks is of course the outlaw mc version
of hamlet himself
in an interview around the time of his
exit perlman shared that his departure
wasn't the result of any behind the
scenes drama
if you're looking for someone to blame
blame shakespeare the hellboy actor told
entertainment weekly
i'm playing claudius and claudius
doesn't make it to act 5.
so i was ready for this if it's an
examination of power
you have to see the new king when he's
not mirrored by the resonances of the
old king
you have to see what he does when he
stands alone in the world
and as long as clay is around he can't
do that
it was it was a very strange
departure clay had to leave sons of
anarchy for the same narrative
considerations that drove shakespeare to
clear off claudius before the final act
of his most famous play
and it had real narrative consequences
for jack's teller
one of the ways charlie hunnam prepared
for jax to murder clay was to ignore his
co-star on set for the entire duration
of season six
as hunnam told entertainment weekly i
decided as difficult as it was going to
be
i wasn't going to talk with ron perlman
not even say good morning to him
and not tell him why i was doing it i
just hoped he would understand
to know that it was just about work and
that it wasn't anything personal
luckily pearlman and hunnam exchanged
kind words after their final scene
together was in the can
but for the sake of perlman's mental
health it sounds like the exit came
just in the nick of time as the actor
explained to entertainment weekly
i started to have trouble with the stuff
i was being asked to do because
i couldn't find a way that i can justify
it to myself i had to resign myself to
playing this guy in a detached way
here's hoping that the great ron perlman
gets to play a few more good guys in the
future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you